the National Security Council Richard
Clarke and his new book is called your
government failure thank you for joining
us this morning really we want to get
the discussion underway with some of
your comments before the September 11th
Commission in 2004 so to the genesis for
the title of the book we'll give our
viewers a chance to look and and you can
comment after week let's take a look I
also welcome the hearings because it is
finally a forum where I can apologize a
25-second to the loved ones of the
victims of 9/11 to them who are here in
the room to those who are watching on
television your government failed you
those entrusted with protecting you
failed you and I failed you we tried
hard but that doesn't matter because we
failed and for that failure
I would ask once all the facts are out
for your understanding and for your
forgiveness Richard Clarke what prompted
that apology before the 9/11 Commission
no I thought it was fairly self-evident
and obvious that the government had
failed and as a result of that failure
Americans and others had died and I
thought fairly natural under those
circumstances to to apologize and we we
were charged we were the part of the
government the FBI the CIA charged with
preventing this sort of thing and we
didn't and as a result of that people
died I thought done and rather I'll be
institution apologize your new book is
your government failed you write a lot
about the Department of Homeland
Security how well have they improved our
domestic security since its inception
well that is the title of the book your
government failure it's not about 9/11
when I said your government failed you I
assumed speaking about 9/11 that that
was
a fairly rare event in American history
and I assumed the failures related to
terrorism and related issues would stop
after 9/11 and in fact there had been
many more failures and to some extent
even larger failures since 9/11 homeland
security I think is one of them frankly
if you remember the history of the
creation of this department
it's the largest second largest
department and the government largest
after the Defense Department President
Bush didn't like the idea I didn't like
the idea governor Ridge who would come
in after 9/11 into the White House
didn't like the idea even of creating a
department we're in the middle of going
after al-qaeda were in the middle of
reducing our vulnerabilities around the
country and people wanted to have us
focus on bureaucratic issues and in
Washington when you're doing a
reorganization of any size people focus
on where their desk is and do they have
a window with a view and who their
boston's and all of those things rather
than on the substance of the job so you
want to keep reorganization to a minimum
then what happened was that the Congress
over here wanted to do something I want
to be seen to be doing something after
9/11 and so Sandra Lieberman who was
Democrat the time proposed this
department he took recommendations from
some Commission's that had been studying
these issues and took those
recommendations pretty much lock stock
and barrel and they started to move a
bill and it was looking really good to
pass in the house and to pass in the
Senate with republicans voting forward
as well as democrats and so we told the
president this his legislative affairs
people came up with with the head count
and they said oops and turned on a dime
from opposing the idea to saying it was
their idea and the president walked out
into the Rose Garden made the
announcement that he came up with this
brilliant idea now we should have a
Department of Homeland
gurgi without so much as referencing the
fact that it was a Labour proposal so we
had one even though we didn't want one
even though he didn't think it was a
good idea and I don't think it's worked
it has a higher percentage of political
appointees than any department in the
entire federal government when it should
have had a lower percentage because it
should be a nonpartisan expert security
focused organization we want to get a
chance here to bring our c-span viewers
into the conversation numbers are on
your screen for republicans 202 737
triple zero one Democrats 202 737 triple
zero two independents and all others two
oh two six two eight zero two zero five
and outside the US special line set
aside two oh two six two eight zero one
eight for your book book covers a lot of
areas where the government has failed
you talk about the Defense Department
and talk about energy and a number of
other things but you come from the
background of a career government
employee who has seen a lot of successes
you think the federal government is
capable of that level of success again
not without some fundamental changes I
think that the federal government has
done some marvelous things and people in
politics tend to use the federal
government as a political punching bag
and they want to run against the
government or they run against
Washington want to run against
bureaucrats and they want to run against
regulation those are all bad words now
highly charged words bureaucrats
regulation federal government people
tend to forget because of all that
propaganda over many years what the
federal government has done and what it
does every day for them and the fact
that regulation and bureaucrats are
improving the quality of their lives and
when regulation and bureaucrats fail the
quality of the American life diminishes
what brought you into government service
to begin with a gorgeous start I started
the Pentagon I was of an age when Jack
Kennedy became president and called for
us to join the government
he had a call for public service ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
not had an impression of my generation
let's hear from our callers Austin Texas
on a Republican line you're first up
with Richard Clarke this rule Clarke and
you're against all enemies book YouTube
you wouldn't talk about America support
for Israel as being the root cause for
9/11 and Jane Stanford conveys that in
pretextual war book the Walton marshana
book on the Israel lobby conveys that
Texas we're going to remind you of our
policy
thirty days please refrain from calling
a c-stand program given thirty days and
give us a call back Sandusky Ohio on our
Democrats line go ahead yes how you guys
doing today
fine thanks hello c-span colors yes I
have three comments first off I tried to
call when Scott McClellan was on on the
30th my friend passed away in Iraq war
Charles Road Odom's the second and he
had opportunity to save him I always my
second comment I always felt like for
last weekend I would say that Scott
McCullen was like Luc Longley and and
who knows Longley nobody does because he
was on Michael Jordan's team and won the
championship with them and Michael
Jordan is Bush nobody's talking about
Michael Jordan they're talking about Luc
Longley Scott McCullen so my third
comment is also I'll pick up on the last
caller's point um could you answer his
question it seems like c-span didn't
want to get that question answered now
thank you very much sir now I'd be glad
to answer it um when whether the al
Qaeda started when bin Laden started it
in the late 1980s all throughout the 90s
as it was building it talked about
Israel hardly at all it's very different
from Hamas and Hezbollah and the other
Islamic terrorist groups in that regard
in that al Qaeda really didn't care too
much about that issue in terms of what
its goal was its goal was not to
overthrow the Israeli government so much
as to overthrow our government
his balance said that the people who
were running the governments of Egypt
and Saudi Arabia and these other
countries were apostate that they were
phony Muslims and they needed to be
overthrown and replaced by real Muslims
ie them and it wasn't until fairly late
in the 1990s probably 98 99 thereafter
but bin Laden and Zawahiri his deputy
started to lace their comments a little
bit with comments about Israel were you
picking this up when you were in the
counterterrorism oh yeah oh yeah we we
you know we're aware that America's
support for Israel which is something
with I support we're aware that that
causes people in the Islamic world to be
upset but I don't think if the
palestinian-israeli problem disappeared
overnight if there were peace and
harmony throughout Israel and Palestine
and Syria and Jordan Lebanon they would
still be in Al Qaeda and it would still
want to do what it wants to do because
that's really not central to their
beliefs Tampa Florida is next and
independent caller good morning good
morning mr. Clarke in 98 there was
legislation submitted to the Senate to
seal the cockpit doors on airliner and I
recall that that was based on the
intelligence we were receiving from 95
on could you tell us why that bill was
killed who killed that bill who was
behind that because talk about
preemption we could have preempted that
strike and I'll hang up and listen thank
ya I'm not familiar with the details of
how that bill was defeated or what
happened to it I can guess however
because we still have similar issues the
airline industry opposed a lot of
security measures that people proposed
before 9/11 now the airline pilots won't
do something where they want to move the
door back and have a second door further
back in the in the cabin and the airline
industry opposes that today they oppose
having pilots having guns
they proposed a lot of it because it
costs the money and as we all know the
airlines are in tough shape financially
but if you have these regulations on all
airlines then they affect them all
equally and there's no competitive
advantage to anyone so ah this is a one
of the themes in the book how industry
pushes back on security regulations and
succeeds where the government usually
gives in to the industries it's supposed
to be regulating you talked the book is
about a lot of government failures the
bush administration has made the case
numerous times about the fact that we
have not been attacked since 9/11 is
this a success or a failure well it's
obviously a success the question is why
is it why is it the case it's not
certainly because we've sealed the
border we haven't sealed the border
millions of people cross the border
illegally every year so that's not the
reason it's not because we've made it
hard to get arms in this country whether
it's sophisticated hand guns and other
weapons and bombing bomb-making material
or even radiological material those
things are all still kind of easy to get
here in this country I think it is in
part because the venue moved to places
like Iraq where we've had 4,000 American
dead and 25,000 American wounded who
have had 30,000 American casualties over
there admittedly not here but for the
terrorists we made it easy for them to
kill Americans over there and they had
the impression that we had made it hard
to come here Deer Park Washington is
next a Republican caller good morning
good morning gentlemen Jonnie a go ahead
here the government has been fabulously
successful they created the oxymoron
endless math loose and let me tell you
why Homeland Security look she is an
American citizen I have to go through a
body cavity search to fly from Spokane
to San Diego but anybody can run
anything
want up our southern and northern border
anything and do you think because the
major national media doesn't pay
attention to this I had to flee Los
Angeles because of the Aborn illegal
immigration from everywhere in the world
but the media their own they don't want
to cover it the politicians they won't
speak about it I will tell you that the
government has been seriously successful
they created the oxymoron and the snafu
thank you gentlemen
well I tend to agree with them the it it
would seem to me that if the United
States really was serious about homeland
security by now we would have had a
system we would have broken through this
difficult issue of immigration policy
and I think almost everyone almost all
reasonable people involved in that
immigration debate agree that part of
the solution is to really control the
borders and if we were really serious
about it we could do it people say oh
it's too difficult it's not it's not too
difficult you talked a little bit about
federal regulations this week's CQ
weekly talks about their cover stories
about regulations bigger picture and it
says America is no longer paramount in
the marketplace it may be fashionable to
deplore the decline of US military might
after five years of the war in Iraq that
has drawn upper Batian around the world
but it's also evident that as the global
economy expands US government agencies
are less and less able to supervise
financial activities get a handle on
domestic prices or monitor the safety of
all manner of imported goods just to
draw upon the latest latest headlines
why is that my point my point exactly
because we have developed this culture
in Washington and around the country but
government is bad and regulation is bad
and therefore regulatory agencies have
been filled with commissioners who
oppose regulation we have regulatory
agencies that don't want to do their job
so we had a mortgage meltdown because
the banking regulatory agencies didn't
do their job we have children licking
lead paint off Chinese toys because the
FDA doesn't want to do it sure
and in the security area we have all
sorts of cases where the Homeland
Security Department and other regulatory
agencies have allowed industry to
determine what's adequate for security
next we go to Hayward Wisconsin on our
democratic line go ahead
good morning mr. Clark morning I admire
respect you and what you've stood for
for all these years I'm 79 years old and
the problem I have with our government
for many generations now is the
obsession with secrecy as an example I'd
like you to explain to the audience what
you know about the USS Liberty well the
USS Liberty was a little bit before my
government service so I I really don't
want to speak authoritative Lee about
that but I am concerned as well about
secrecy I think the number of secret
documents generated by the government
has gone up successively in the last
several years there was an attempt in
the 90s to reduce the number of secret
documents and to reveal undie classified
documents from earlier years the trend
now has been in the opposite direct
why's that I'm not too sure no I I think
it's in part because they no longer
believe in the White House and elsewhere
that the government should be
transparent about the public has a right
to know tie that into the chapter you
have in here on site the vulnerability
to us has to cyber security you know
this is another fascinating case like
global warming like al-qaeda before 9/11
where we know there's a problem you know
you talk to any expert Republican
Democrat there's a problem as a problem
with cybersecurity and yet we're failing
to do anything about it until something
really disastrous happens and arguably
really disastrous things are happening
all the time the Chinese government has
hacked Pentagon computers the Chinese
government has hacked the computers of
many large defense contractors in the
United
and it's apparent that the Chinese
government or others could hack into all
sorts of things that control important
parts of our economy they can steal our
industrial secrets they can steal our
military secrets and they could in a
crisis do damage to our electric power
system and other infrastructure if
secrecy is such a high priority then why
isn't this being addressed I think it's
again it goes back to not wanting the
government to do anything if you're
going to take this new problem which no
one's ever really dealt with
successfully before and deal with it you
have to deal with private companies you
have to regulate private companies
because private companies owned the
electric power grid and the banks on the
other infrastructure Haverhill
Massachusetts is next an independent
caller welcome hello you're on the air
go ahead yes I think we worry too much
about other countries and not enough
about our own country all kinds
informations constantly getting stolen
from our country going all kinds of
foreign countries or these foreign
countries they attack us they badmouth
ops and here we go we give them all our
money
it's totally ludicrous I can't stand it
I think it I think it's all bogus I mean
you don't buy friends yearn for one
thing is these people you know they give
money to terrorists and they give money
to is really give money to terrorists
they give money to Israel to fight back
and forth or do we give the most money
to all it's doing is causing problems
and their problems ain't our problems
all these countries were given the money
to over there Jordan they give money
gives off the weapons we give them they
give to our enemies I mean more garlic
after 9/11 you see them up there
threaten our sort of tax and we give
money to Egypt I mean we really need to
start taking care our selves and not
worry about all these Turks that
backstab us Richard Clarke so first of
all I think it's Haverhill laughter no
since I grew up in bath I think that's
really great decided for Mitchell always
good to get the geography right I think
if you if you talk about giving money to
other countries
United States doesn't really do that
very much as a percentage of our economy
we're probably less in terms of foreign
aid and most industrialized developed
countries and when we do give money
usually not money most foreign aid is
tied to a program so there's money to
stop the proliferation of nuclear
weapons there's money to stop illegal
narcotics there's money to stop criminal
organizations there's money to stop
trafficking and persons particularly the
trafficking women so if you look at that
State Department foreign aid bill
everybody likes to beat up on and ask do
you want to give money in other
countries everyone will say no if you
ask do you think we should spend some
money overseas to stop the proliferation
of nuclear weapons or to stop the clear
weapons from getting into the United
States or drugs or illegal immigrants
then the answer is automatically yes do
you think we should give money to have
other people's police and intelligence
agencies stop al Qaeda rather than
having the Americans do it all the time
then the answer is yes and if you total
up all these yeses you get to about 85
90 percent of the foreign aid bill we
showed your clip a little bit earlier
about the 9/11 Commission and you were
apologizing to the families of 9/11 what
do you what do you write in your book
about the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina
how was the government's failure there
the government's failure there was
almost complete and I say almost because
there was one agency that did a very
good job at that was the United States
Coast Guard and it did it instantly
automatically and without even reporting
to Washington helicopters from
throughout the United States Coast Guard
helicopters just moved because that's
what they do
even from Massachusetts helicopters
moved and were replaced by the Canadians
Coast Guard but the everything else in
the federal government failed to work
and one reason I believe was that FEMA
had been decimated of its experts and
political appointees had been put over
how long of a period did that happened
it had begun in 2001 it had been true
before and then in the in the 1990s
it was d politicized to a very large
extent and then the politicization
occurred again there's also a failure of
leadership on lots of different agencies
at the state level so you can we have a
city level but also in the White House
let's go to Annapolis Maryland on our
Republicans line good morning for
Richard Clark
my name is Clark believe if you stand
for your public forum two points really
one is I think it's a bit unfair to
characterize homeland security as an
abject failure and and too don't you
think that the reality is is that
federal agencies just like their their a
governing body above them in a democracy
too fast of a commitment is doesn't bode
well in other words a representative is
theirs reflecting this constituents and
the constituents are very therefore a
single position is a complicated I think
this flows down into the agencies the
federal government got blessed for their
further public service and it there is
more the focus that we we have formed an
agency to try and deal with and then
over a period of time it will do its job
thank you I hope over a period of time
it will its own inspector general the
last several inspector general and the
Government Accountability Office have
given it goals and given it grades and
it scores worse than any other
government department consistently on
all sorts of measures of getting things
done objective measures look there are
great people in the Secret Service and
the Coast Guard and ice but as a
department it's not working and that may
be because it's too big and we're asking
it to do too many things
and therefore the mission is not clear
it may be because it's been given too
much political pork to distribute that's
the Congress's fault not on Homeland
Security's fault entirely and it may be
because the leadership frankly hasn't
been what it should have been you
pointed out Coast Guard a success story
for Katrina they're part of Homeland
Security do you think the department
should be reshaped reformed this Coast
Guard stay with Homeland Security again
I believe that reorganizing federal
departments is something you should
rarely do because it takes people's eyes
off the ball that having been said you
know there are some marriages that just
really have to end in divorce
no matter how hard you try because they
really are unreconciled will DIF a--'s
and it's best when you know that when
you recognize that to get it done
our guest is Richard Clarke talking
about his book this latest book is
called your government failed you and
we're taking your calls for the next
half hour the numbers are on the screen
202 737 triple zero one for Republicans
202 737 triple zero to four Democrats
202 6 to 8 0 to 0-5 for independence and
all others Cranston Rhode Island on our
Democrats line go ahead
Cranston go ahead Thank You mr. Clarke I
have ly I admire you as a non-us person
I have three and three points to make I
like for for you to answer to me on the
first question is that many of us and
many American people marry Europeans
feel that President Bush a committed war
crimes in the in attacking a nation that
did not pose threats there are abu gray
madonna MoBay and killing our soldiers
be propaganda on the Tillman that's the
number one if you agree that the
international community should bring a
mouth after office for war crimes my
second point is that we all know that
the propaganda I have not even finished
high school then I admire you when you
came out and speak against the war
because I know you were saying
to me as a guy that don't have much
education knew the whole thing is
propaganda by seems to me that
propaganda instilled is moving on
towards Europe toes toes Iran and with
the Patriota Lieberman and McCain they
try to put us in another war and I like
to know that your opinion how much gas
will be after that and my third point is
that I was up with our if you support I
know that you are support Israel and we
also support Israel but we should be we
should be live a fair one a fair handed
and I like for you to that will tell me
if you support the 1967 bub
treatment and if you support up for the
Israelis building are the settlements in
Israel in East Jerusalem because it
seems to me that blogging was very
serious about free Palestine and I think
personally that if we can have two-state
solution through peace over there I
think the tone of terrorism it will
eventually die thank you for taking my
call Thank You Rhode Island was the
water first on war crimes about the Bush
administration I don't think we should
have the international community
investigating the United States
government but I do think we need to
think seriously about some sort of truth
and reconciliation process in the United
States to see what happened on a whole
host of issues regarding the
Constitution and civil liberties and the
conduct of our foreign policy over the
last few years and maybe maybe what we
need is a an American government
commission to see what happened and how
we might fix it with regard to around we
can talk about that at great length but
my bottom line on Iran is before we use
military force
we better be darn sure that we know what
the result of that will be we utter you
as : Powell's doctrine which says among
other things you have to exhausted low
Matic means and you have to know at the
end
will be I'm not an ulcer I've heard
anybody explain what the endgame would
be after we used military force and
finally on Israel and the 67 borders I
think the 67 borders form a basis for
the ultimate peace deal but I think
there will be some trading back and
forth some territory that was inside
will be outside and vice versa but I
think the 67 borders formed the basis
and then there's the knotty issue of
what you do about Jerusalem Detroit is
next on our independent line go ahead
thank you and good morning three points
I want to make first of all with the
Israeli problem I suggest people read a
book that they say is not real but it
definitely is like a blueprint what's
going on today is called the protocols
of the learned Elders of Zion I'm sorry
secondly the 911 tech you know there's a
information that Cheney took over the
what is it called of the SEC thing where
the airplanes that protect our
ever-changing air command yes the
Strategic Air Command they are for the
first time in history 50 years with Vice
President took control of that and they
have them stand down during that time
they ran our tests and when one G Third
Point gone and the Third Point was askew
at that kind of destructive it was that
with the homeland security it seems to
ring like sort of like the program they
ran in Germany after they created a
false flag operation and burn it down to
Rostov they came up with the motherland
security which was basically uh you know
to police their own people like what the
see like is happening here you know
that's pretty much it
well let mr. Clark reply yeah I really
don't want to comment on any of those
things I I think you know there are some
of these urban legends and terrible
myths that just float around about 9/11
other
things and I just don't want to give
them any currency by talking about you
run it at all in the book about the role
of Vice President Cheney in terms of the
national security of the US yeah I do
I think the Cheney had a vast influence
and continues to have a vast influence
over the government it was bigger back
when his best friend in the world was
the Secretary of Defense and what the
two of them were able to do was Rumsfeld
would take things directly the trainee
Cheney would take them directly to the
president and the system would never see
them there's a reason we have a system
it's a matter of checks and balances
it's a matter of accountability it's a
matter of accuracy and oversight and
they cut out the National Security
Council system that Harry Truman
established in 1947 the nice and how are
expanded we have a national security
council system of we used to have one
anyway of nonpartisan people experts who
were designed to make sure that
everything was checked and analyzed and
there were options and they were
opposing views all that got cut out
you served President Bush until 2003 in
the National Security Council how soon
did you observe this sort of bypassing
almost immediately you write in the book
about energy one of your chapters is
about an energy I'd like to read a
little bit from it because it ties into
some of the Senate debate today in that
Middle East war and in the current one
part of the rationale for going to war
with the notion that we need to secure
sources of oil it is a simple argument
for the public to latch onto and it's
largely wrong neither war neither war
was really about oil and fighting a war
tends to disrupt not improve the flow of
oil as I write this in March of 2008
five years into the war in Iraq oil is
hovering above $100 a barrel if the war
was started to secure cheap source of
oil we have done a heck of a job yet
based on that false notion we fight wars
over oil calls are now getting louder
for the United States to achieve energy
independence something a parade of
presidents over the last 30 years have
pledged to do then failed to achieve in
the global economy you right achieving
independence
on anything is an unrealistic goal
pursuing it will be costly in terms of
dollars we'll do nothing to improve our
national security and will distract us
from the real threat to our national
security that stems from our energy
policies that's climate change the
Senate's about to debate a climate
change bill today why is that the real
threat to our national security well
there's a lot of myth in this issue of
energy policy
one myth which I touched on briefly
there is the notion that we went to war
in 1990 and in 2004 to get oil you don't
have to go to war to get oil no country
that has oil is going to sit on it
they're going to export it as soon as
they export it into the international
marketplace
it's available and you don't divert oil
away from the United States it's in the
international marketplace we can get it
the other myth is energy independence
Richard Nixon was the first president I
could find who said in a State of the
Union address we will achieve energy
independence he said the goal of 1980
every president since then has set a
goal of energy independence mean meaning
we don't import any energy well every
country in the world including Iran and
Saudi Arabia and Iraq and Kuwait all the
big oil producers every country in the
world
imports energy no country in the world
has enough of the diverse sources of
energy that one needs and the refineries
that one needs to be able to do it all
by themselves there's nothing special
about oil and gas from the United States
if it's more expensive to get oil out of
the ground in the United States or if
it's the wrong kind of oil then you get
it overseas there's also this myth that
by buying oil overseas we're funding
terrorism and we're fighting both sides
funding both sides of the war on terror
people say totally untrue no one has
ever been able to document a case where
the countries that we buy our oil from
which are largely Canada Mexico is whele
Nigeria and Saudi Arabia that those
governments
our funding terrorism it's myth the
issue of climate change being a security
what makes climate change a national
security issue if climate change occurs
the way 90 percent 95 percent of the
scientists believe it will occur it will
change the balance of power in the world
and we will be on the wrong end of that
stick our major coastal cities will
flood will have to spend trillions of
dollars to save those cities they'll be
drought in other parts of our country
another Dust Bowl as there as there was
briefly in the 1930s and we'll have to
spend trillions of dollars to move those
cities and to bring in water and do
desalinization at the same time other
countries and Russia is probably one of
them will have their power increased
because certain parts of their country
that they couldn't use through the
permafrost will now be usable next color
or Richard Clarke is Buffalo New York on
our Republican line good morning good
morning Mr Clarke when of course want to
thank you for your service I'm a retired
Navy I retired in June of 2001 like you
I was called to service then my
background in aviation security I was
they ended up being a senior field
director for TSA during my time there I
found that TSA hired many people who
were unqualified or simply we're not
wanted in the FAA for one reason or
another then as a result of that I saw a
lot of abuse mismanagement people taking
care of friends but not taking care of
public security and I think this caused
a lack of credibility between the
agencies my question for you is do you
have any hope that TSA will evolve into
a credible or respectable agency and
actually take care of public security
and specifically aviation security for
our nation if not what is the
alternative well I don't think there's
an alternative I think we have to make
it work
TSA was created overnight and went from
nothing to 40,000 people in less than a
year and we did have to scramble to find
people and to steal them from other
agencies I think there is inherent in
its mission a problem of quality control
of the staff and they have to be
motivated and they have to be trained
and they have to be given decent
equipment and unfortunately the
administration has been talking about
cutting back TSA I think what we need to
do is make sure that they are better
trained and that their equipment is
state-of-the-art and that we put our
priorities in the right place having
everybody take off their shoes and all
that phone sense that we go through
could really be avoided and lots of
these long lines could be avoided if we
had ID cards if everybody had ID cards
not just people who are willing to pay
$100 form and if we had technology that
could scan more appropriately and
quicker all that's going to cost money
and the administration has been saying
it wants to cut back the budget of TSA
well if the American taxpayer is upset
with TSA unfortunately in the near term
the solution is to spend more money on
it to get it better technology and
better training and to get us all ID
cards rather than to cut back on it
walleston is next on our Democrats line
oh good morning Maury
mr. Clarke I have to say that when you
initially came out and you spoke out
about the failures of the US government
I was very proud of you and I commend
you for doing that
however my problem is and continues to
be is the culture of cowardice and that
permeates and Washington and
unfortunately whistleblowers like you
like Scott McClellan and many other
people suffer from the same culture of
cowardice and the lack of courage which
is to speak about the central role that
the us-israeli relationship
please in determining your security and
now you're an intelligent man I am sure
you you know you you watch bin Laden's
messages when they come out and bin
Laden said quote I thought about the
idea of hitting the towers in New York
when I saw the towers of Beirut being
burned by Shalom in 1982 that's number
one number two since 2001
how many 911 in Arab human lives as
Israel killed number two and number
three who were the most prominent
lobbyists in DC beating the drums of war
against Iraq after 9/11 Frank thanks
Boston will give mr. Clark a chance to
reply well I think I said a little
earlier in the broadcast that I really
think that Al Qaeda's propaganda about
Israel is a relatively new phenomenon
in the second half of its life as an
organization and if Israel and Palestine
reached agreement al Qaeda would still
be around and still be doing what it's
doing there it's certainly true that
there were people who were supporters of
Israel who were engaged in the
propaganda and the lying prior to the
Iraq war it is also true that there were
many supporters of Israel's right to
exist and backers of the issue of
supporting Israel's security who were
opposed to the war like me there were
lots of us so I don't think you can say
just because there were people in favor
of the war and in the lead in the
propaganda who also supported Israel's
security that that was their motivation
why it's been so difficult to the
capture bin Laden well in part because
we're not really focused on going after
al Qaeda to the extent that we should be
after 9/11 it was the focus for about
six to eight months
and then we started taking special
forces that were in Afghanistan out of
Afghanistan to get them ready for the
Iraq war and we took reconnaissance
assets that were in Afghanistan out to
get them ready for the Iraq war so long
before we even invaded Iraq we were
pulling assets off the search for bin
Laden and al-qaeda to get them ready to
go into a wholly unnecessary war in Iraq
now being an outside observer of the
National Security Council our security
how would you gauge al-qaeda's influence
now al-qaeda's influence has to be
looked at regionally certainly its
influence in Iraq has diminished and in
the last year or so I'd say its
influence in Pakistan and Afghanistan
has actually increased and that tracks
with the National Intelligence Estimate
and the statements by CIA director
Hayden general Hayden and the Director
of National Intelligence Admiral
McConnell they've both said Iraq is
reconstituting itself Iraq is a stronger
al-qaeda is I'm sorry al Qaeda is
reconstituting itself in Pakistan al
Qaeda is now stronger than it has been
since perhaps 2000 to 2003 and that's
because Pakistan has in essence allowed
a sanctuary to develop in northwest
Pakistan let's hear from new orange from
Orange Connecticut and independent
caller go ahead good morning yes good
morning I just want to point to you the
host I think it's you know first of
o'clock I appreciate you and I believe
your intentions are good I please no
intentions all about this country and
any other country that you know talks
about doing the right thing but I wish
disbanding the host of c-span once you
do have a guest such as this particular
guest and you take calls and you say to
the audience we're going to take your
calls I mean be mindful that the callers
are on the phone but 15 and 20 minutes
waiting to ask the question and by the
time the call comes around to the person
on the other line
to ask the question they probably forgot
what they wanted to ask be sensitive to
the call is and I think the primary
thing with c-span is that this is the
only program that we can
we learn and question facts so just feel
a little more sensitive to the callers
that are online but mr. Clark you've
answered most of what I wanted to know
and I already know most of it that Dick
Cheney is really the one who runs the
White House and the administration has
lied to the American public my one
question I like you to answer is based
on what you've observed McCullen's had
the treatment of McCowen similar
treatment that you actually experienced
yourself do you can you tell me why he
wouldn't use the word that you used that
they lied well I think he actually has
said that there were lies
I haven't watched every every show he's
been on because he's been on that pretty
much every TV show in the country but I
think he has said the word law if he
hasn't been surprised because he
certainly conveyed the impression that
they've been lying and said that they
mislead people I think he's been pretty
clear about that Dallas Texas a
Republican caller go ahead for Richard
Clark yes mr. Clark
i-i've sit and listen to you and this
morning I'm very proud to be an American
with the exception of a couple points
you write a book of how you have failed
us or how the government has failed us
but you in other end when a man on the
phone
asked you a question about a possible
conspiracy or a possible something in
our country that is happening that we
are not being well informed and that we
are not gaining the access to
information that we should have and that
our civil liberties are being taken away
at the same point when you say you have
failed us or the government's failed us
and you are a part of that you have to
be more human in the aspect that the
internet puts out information daily that
is in abundance that people can read
should they want to read should they
want to find out answers they can find
out let me give you an example you said
the government failed us in the aspect
of a program such as HAARP H AARP you
know what it is it was probable
involved in the time were being invented
in the time that you were in the White
House if it was not already being part I
am suggesting that there are programs
and things that you say you have failed
us but you give us half-truths
I don't know why that is if you are
going to step out and write a book and
say you failed us then step out and
write the book and list them in
chronological order because some of the
things you talk about in the the
government has failed you that you only
give us a taste for reading a book I
would rather read my Constitution and
know that it's being a rate of basically
eroded in its aspect because of things
you come out and talk
McCullen comes out and talked that's
wonderful but half-truths get us nowhere
if you failed line it up so we don't
fail again god bless america because
right now we're in trouble because
people only want to tell you what they
want to write a book for okay Texas well
look I entirely agree that the
Constitution has been abused in the last
several years sheva liberties have been
eroded in the last several years and I
do in the book go through in
chronological order the failures I'm
unaware of the H AARP program I will
loan if it's on the internet I'll go
home and look it up but I don't know
what it is I I don't think that we
should have hasturs you refer to a
caller earlier who asked some questions
I wouldn't respond to they were they
were at least two of them the popular
myths of the lunatic fringe and one of
them was grossly anti-semitic and was in
fact invented by adolphe Hitler and the
Nazis and I'm just not going to talk
about that I don't want to give currency
to that sort of thing next up is Roanoke
Virginia on our independence line for
Richard Clarke good morning good morning
word if you could comment in a personal
way about how long all of this business
that that was just brought to light by
Scott McCall of McClellan's a book and
the idea of the permanent campaign and I
wonder if you'd been inside and out
side of the bubble that he talked about
and if you could comment in a way about
how this affected you at the time that
you were going through it and maybe
contrast your work with both the Clinton
administration and and then Bush later
on also could you tell us did Bush did
the Bush administration have it in their
minds to go into Iraq when they came
into office let me answer the last part
first I think senior officials in
probably including the vice president
the Secretary of Defense and and a few
others senior officials in the in the
Bush administration I am convinced had
it in mind to go into Iraq when they
came into office I think the president
was not quite there but 9/11 kind of
pushed him over the top on that even
though they were unconnected he he saw a
connection and people saw connection and
explained it to him but there was one
when there wasn't on the personal basis
I think what Scott McClellan is probably
going through and this notion of living
in a bubble in the White House I think
it's true I think when you when you work
18 hours a day as senior folks do in the
White House and you work six or seven
days a week and all your friends that
you get to see those rare occasions when
you have time off are people for the
most part who are connected to the White
House you live in the world of
groupthink and you don't understand some
of the dialogue that's going on some of
the perspectives that exist outside that
bubble does it happen in other agencies
paper oh sure I think it does but
particularly in the White House let's go
to Chicago Chicago's next on our
democratic line good morning for Richard
Clark
good morning mr. Clark I wanted to ask
you a question on a variation I wanted
to ask the Canadian ambassador to
Afghanistan earlier and that was you
know although there are in urban legends
and myths that distract from what is
doable and valuable I found it useful
back several Wars and Buuren
Persis to pay attention to jokes to
quips to insults to graffiti that
sometimes tell you a ground truth it
doesn't always bubble up on the
cybersecurity end for example regarding
Windows XP there was way too friendly
for your own good
what kind of things if any are you
hearing that we out in the general
public are not getting that that might
be valuable that stick in the mind that
get the mind focused on it on the
problem directed toward a solution well
on the conspiracy theory saying I think
what the caller mentions about looking
for sources of information outside the
usual sources of information is very
valuable and I don't reject conspiracy
theories on hand in fact it was my job
in the White House on security related
conspiracy theories to check them out
and I I did with an open mind usually
99% of the time we were able to debunk
them and I write about this in the book
there are a couple that we didn't quite
run to ground but I think you do have to
look at them and you do have to do what
the intelligence community calls open
source analysis look for information
even if it's just a little hint of
what's going on in unusual places in the
case of cybersecurity I think you pretty
much understand the problem operating
systems the applications are not secure
and I think you have to be very very
careful and you have to take
extraordinary measures to achieve
security it's a lot to ask for the
individual home user to do and you can
spend a lot of time trying to secure
your computer I think we have to take
that burden away from the average home
user and try to have the the providers
the Internet service providers the the
Comcast's the Verizon's there have them
do a lot more of the cybersecurity
function does that have to be legislated
it has to be regulated the FCC has the
authority to do that and it's looked at
it and of course the industry has how
old and therefore it hasn't been done
let's hear from Columbus Ohio on our
independence lawn couple more calls for
Richard Clark good morning good morning
mr. Clark Atlanta to talk to you I read
your first book and I was fascinated and
I thank you so much for coming out and
exposing some of the things that you did
two quick questions
scott mcclellan on Meet the Press
yesterday claimed in rebuttal but there
was a cliff shown in Krita criticizing
you strongly years ago for come out with
your first book and he claimed that he
had apologized to you personally
recently I was wondering if that was
true and my second question is I believe
strongly whatever the administration is
next needs your service sir that we need
you involved in security this nation and
I was wondering if you would consider
service under either a McCain or a
democratic undetermined nominee
administration I know would like you to
come to Columbus with a book to her
please would love to have you sign my
book thank you yeah it is in fact true
that Scott McClellan and I met in a
bizarre situation we we were both
apparently staying in the whole same
hotel in New York last week and he
literally came through a revolving door
I start to believe because of the
metaphor but he literally came through a
revolving door and bumped into me and we
had a brief chat and he did ask me to
accept his apology for what he had said
about me as a White House spokesman and
I get I did accept his apology I look
I'm a big believer in forgiveness and
apologies the 9/11 victims families
forgave me for my inadequacy in stopping
the 9/11 attack and far be it for me not
to accept an apology right so I did
last call for Richard Clarke st. Charles
Illinois a Republican caller good
morning go ahead hi miss Clarke I agree
with you a lot of these call
is there been troubling they've been the
deeply anti-israel and as you said
deeply anti-semitic but I want to ask
you a question about Hezbollah recently
Michael Chertoff and before in richard
armitage that Hezbollah actually is the
greatest threat to America and I sort of
agree with that because Hezbollah right
now has a state at its disposal you know
that state being Lebanon being funded by
Syrian and Iran and to me that's the
biggest threat because they have
legitimacy so-called
in the an access to weapons and
intelligence that al-qaeda can only
dream of what do you think of I agree I
agree entirely I think his below is the
most capable terrorist organization in
the world right now has been for some
time much more capable has always been
more capable than al Qaeda makes them
more capable Iran they are in many ways
an extension of the Iranian government
Richard Clarke's new book your
government failed you you're a professor
at the Harvard study Kennedy School and
government professor I'm a faculty
member at the Kennedy School of
Government I'm an adjunct and I teach a
course up there called national security
management as a as a professor is your
view of government now is that it half
empty or half full I think it's way
below half empty and it's it's it's at a
low point and I think no matter who gets
elected just changing out the president
and the top it's not going to fix it the
new president and that president's team
is going to have to do some institution
rebuilding Richard Clark thanks for
joining us this morning thank you